[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de la tamise
interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
l'historien bruno fuligni qui nous
dévoile dans son livre la fille de
napoléon une nouvelle énigme de
l'histoire de france
charlotte chappuis qui surgissent à
l'âge de 20 ans juste après waterloo et
que foucher le ministre de la police se
dépêcher de faire mettre au cachot et
elle la fille naturelle de l'empereur il
va nous raconter son enquête et méline
agassi pour son livre elles ont été les
premières illustré par go margut le
portrait de 100 femmes exceptionnelles
qui ont contribué à l avènement du girl
power mais l'on commence tout de suite
par notre époque qu'est ce qui
caractérise ce début de xxième siècle
voici vos réponses en images
ça c'est la vôtre bélisle agassi une
photo d'yves saint laurent
pourquoi lui bien parce que je sais pas
ça m'est venu comme ça j'ai été du j'ai
été très triste moment de sa mort je
n'avais jamais eu les moyens de me payer
des vêtements du saint laurent mais j'ai
j'ai trouvé que c'était comme un mauvais
signe de la fin de l'élégance de la fin
de la liberté de la fin de la créativité
je n'ai jamais été vraiment à fond dans
les fêtes des années 80 et des années
d'avant mais j'avais une sorte de 2,2 on
va dire entre guillemets je sais pas
recommandé de le sentiment amoureux pour
yves saint laurent que je regrette
profondément de ne pas avoir connu je
m'étais même fait faire un un manteau
par une couturière mauvais que j'ai
toujours et j'ai toujours une pensée
pour lui parce que je trouve que c'était
vraiment un créateur et peut-être que
aujourd'hui surtout au moment de cette
de cette pandémie mon manque de
créativité enfin selon moi un de liberté
de d'insouciance je pense que sa mort
m'a frappée parce qu'elle pour moi elle
signe un peu la fin de quelque chose
peut-être le renouveau de quelque chose
d'autre hostile qu'on attend espérons le
en tout cas et vous à bueno aires
nos fils signé la photo que vous avez
choisi c'est celle ci alors racontez
nous une photo étrange si on la regarde
rapidement d'abord on pense à de la
police scientifique
si on regarde les ossements ils ont
l'air tout de même un petit peu trop
anciens pour être ceux des victimes d'un
serial-killer contemporain en fait c'est
un étrange mélange des deux un choc de
deux époques
ces restes sont tout simplement ceux du
général du daim un général du premier
empire qui est mort en russie on avait
perdu sa tombe
on a retrouvé ses restes ils ont été
identifiés grâce à des tests adn
ils vont bientôt réintégrer la la france
et que dis-je les invalides à l'occasion
des cérémonies du bicentenaire de
napoléon et c'est ça qui m'a intéressé
c'est d'avoir ce télescopage du premier
empire et de l'époque contemporaine avec
toutes ces techniques en une seule photo
alors on a jamais reçus dans cette
émission père pierre malinowski qui est
celui qui a retrouvé les les restes du
gérald godin c'est un chercheur de
tombes
il a publié la recherche du tombeau
perdu il était venu dans cette émission
et c'est vrai que la cérémonie aux
invalides a toujours été reculé à cause
du coc vide injustement sait il aurait
dû revenir bien plus vite
oui mais il y as je l'espère autour du 5
mai date anniversaire de la mort de
napoléon 1er
peut-être une opportunité intéressante
et bien commençons
[Musique]
nous sommes en effet en 2021 et on
commémore le 200e anniversaire de la
mort de l'empereur et vous publiez bono
fuligni la fille de napoléon aux
éditions les arènes pendant l'été 1815
juste après waterloo surgit au milieu
des soldats autrichiens qui occupe la
france une jeune femme de 20 ans du nom
de charlotte chappuis qui se prétend la
fille de napoléon
alors elle est née quand et 2 qui alors
on sait précisément quand elle est née
elle est née le 22 août
1795 dans une ville que nous appelons
aujourd'hui arnay-le-duc en bourgogne
qui s'appelait évidemment harnais sur
arroux au moment de la révolution y
avait plus de duke donc lé bourguignonne
on sait qui est sa mère une certaine
antoinette cattin épouse chappuis mais
il ya un mystère sur son père est ce
monsieur chapuis dont on sait peu de
chose ou est ce plutôt un jeune officier
prometteur qui fréquentaient la
bourgogne à cette époque là un certain
napoléon bonaparte
c'est ce que antoinette cattin dira à sa
fille tu es la fille de ce jeune
officier corse que j'ai rencontré il ya
bien longtemps et secret qui va d'abord
restée familiale
charlotte se dévoile en 1815 donc au
moment où napoléon est aux mains des
anglais
et alors là ça crée une véritable
affaire d'état c'est quelque chose qui
était très très très peu connu jusqu'à
maintenant et j'ai eu la chance de
retrouver le dossier de cette affaire
d'état avec un rapport en particulier
qui est remonté jusqu'à foucher le
ministre de la police générale on
reviendra sur ce dossier un mais
pourquoi est-ce que charlotte n'a pas
essayé de contacter son père napoléon
1er du temps qu'il était au pouvoir
pourquoi arrive t elle tout à coup un
boîtier nu ou la décrivez sortant d'un
sous bois pour se jeter
se présentait aux soldats autrichiens
pourquoi pas avant alors sa mère meurt
et peut-être même s'est elle suicidée
quelques jours après la naissance de
l'aiglon il est difficile de se déclarer
comme cela ou à la cour des tuileries
fille naturelle de l'empereur à partir
du moment où il a eu une descendance
légitime
et puis charlotte a peur et elle a
raison d'avoir peur car à partir du
moment où elle va effectivement faire
savoir son secret bien son affaire ne va
plus rester une affaire privée et
devient une affaire d'état
si elle va voir les autrichiens c'est
parce qu'elle a peur d'être liquidé
liquidée par sans doute les prussiens
qui ont juré d' exterminer la race des
bonaparte peur sans doute aussi des
royalistes français 1 qui sont revenus
au pouvoir vraiment dans les fourgons
des armées étrangères qui ont vaincu
napoléon et qui déferle sur la france
il faut voir que si elle est comme cela
a presque nue apeuré aux portes de
besançon dans un camp militaire
c'est parce qu'on est dans une france
qui est vaincu envahi humilié dévasté où
on n'a aucune certitude du lendemain
c'est dans un contexte vraiment
apocalyptique que cette jeune femme se
déclare fille naturelle de napoléon et
c'est pourquoi alors que elle vit dans
la peur elle va susciter en revanche un
espoir
tous ceux qui ont peur que les
royalistes reviennent à avant la
révolution française rétablisse d'ancien
régime rétablisse tous les privilèges
annuler toutes les réformes de la
révolution ceux là vont se dire tiens si
napoléon est aux mains des anglais né il
ya une fille en liberté pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas rejouer la partie
d'un certain point de vue et c'est ce
que bien sûr la police veut absolument
éviter la police basse et fouché qui est
toujours le ministre de la police à ce
moment là il était déjà celui de de
napoléon
et puis il a des oreilles qui traînent
partout là en l'occurrence c'est un
sorte d'agent secret dont vous ne
connaissez que le pseudonyme un multi
nus ce qui
eux qui qui qui entend parler d'elle le
premier qui remonte la formation à
fouché et la conséquence à l'it
immédiate à on l'enlève et on l'a fait
au cachot oui alors ça se passe au
moment où coucher vit ses derniers
instants comme ministre ou d'abedi il
était au service de napoléon où il est
passé au service du roi louis xviii
quelque temps après la réception du
rapport il va être remplacé par le duc
decazes un nouveau ministre de la police
générale mais la politique reste la même
pas de jeanne d'arc bonapartiste dans
l'est de la france et ne les sont
surtout pas une jeune femme comme elle
tombée enceinte et donner un héritier
qu'on ne contrôleraient pas à la
couronne impériale et donc foucher
instruit par cet agent secret qui signe
son rapport mutine us puis son
successeur de cases et bien la faune
arrêtés emprisonnés et j'insiste c'est
une arrestation arbitraire
elle est mise au secret il n'y a pas de
jugement elle n'est pas attaqué pour
usurpation d'identité imposture
escroquerie quoi que ce soit c'est
vraiment de la police politique
un enlèvement une mise au secret elle
est dans une cellule avec un garde
devant sa cellule
on le sait parce qu'elle essaye de
correspondre de façon clandestine avec
l'extérieur
mais ces lettres ont été interceptés et
se trouve également dans son dossier
donc on a des documents extrêmement
émouvant où c'est charlotte elle même
qui parle qui explique ce qu'elle vit
qui qui témoigne de sa peur et ses
lettres et bien j'ai eu le privilège de
pouvoir les lire d'être sorte moi aussi
d'agents secrets qui tout à coup et
accès à la correspondance intime de la
fille présumée de napoléon et de cases
donc il succède à coucher lui pourquoi
at il intérêt à ce que à ce que cette
jeune femme restera en privant alors
d'abord il ya un intérêt immédiat qui
est exactement le même que foucher
éviter des troubles politiques le roi
louis xviii a été rétablie par les
armées étrangères
il est peu populaire sont rodés très
fragile et on peut pas se permettre
d'avoir comme cela un foyer bonapartiste
qui qui se formerait dans l'est de la
france il ya le danger
qu'elles donnent un nouvel héritier
l'aiglon est encore un tout petit enfant
et il est sous la coupe des autrichiens
faudrait pas qu'ils aient un nouvel
héritier et puis on comprendra beaucoup
plus tard que deux cases et peut-être
lui même le père d'un enfant naturel qui
n'est autre que louis napoléon bonaparte
qui va devenir ma peau léon iii donc
quitte à ce que la couronne impériale un
jour reviennent autant que ce soit son
enfant naturel à lui et non leur enfant
naturel de napoléon bonaparte alors des
enfants naturels napoléon bonaparte en a
eu plusieurs
bon il en a un légitime celle aiglons
qu'on va voir là à peu près à l'âge
qu'il doit avoir à ce moment là au
moment de waterloo à l'aiglon il est en
outre riche avec sa mère marie louise et
il vit chez son grand père l'empereur
d'autriche
on sait que le malheureux ne dépassera
pas sa 21e année mais il ya d'autres
enfants naturels le premier c'est
alexandre walewski le fille de le fils
de marie valeska il ressemble beaucoup à
son père le voilà et il finira
d'ailleurs ministre des affaires
étrangères de louis napoléon bonaparte
ou plus exactement de napoléon iii lui à
ce moment là il est en pologne
il est allé voir son père à l'île d'elbe
1 je crois va les skis oui mais c'est
celle qui est troublant napoléon
bonaparte a pris soin de ses deux fils
naturel dont personne ne conteste la
paternité walewski balle connaître les
deux napoléon 1er et 3 et il fera une
très très belle carrière sous le second
empire où l'avait dit il sera ministre y
sera c'est naturel sera président du
corps législatif l'équivalent de
l'assemblée nationale à l'époque et il
était tout le portrait craché de son
père la ressemblance physique et est
évidente et tous ceux qui l'ont
rencontré l'ont souligné
et puis il y avait eu un autre enfant
naturel le comte léon
voilà donc un personnage beaucoup moins
fréquentables qui faisait beaucoup de
dettes beaucoup de tapage mais louis
napoléon bonaparte devenu napoléon iii
va prendre soin aussi de d'essayer de le
maîtriser va régulièrement éponger ses
dettes passées un petit peu l'eponge sur
ces phrases de ses duels
tout le tapage qu'il fait c'est plutôt
un raté le comte léon mais a raté
bruyant encombrants néanmoins louis
napoléon bonaparte devenu napoléon iii
aura toujours un oeil sur ses cousins là
et au fond leur rendra service du moment
qu'il ne revendique pas quelque chose
d'un point de vue dynastique
mais alors il ya aussi il ya aussi les
frères de napoléon qui sont toujours
vivants 1 à ce moment là on est toujours
en 1815 il ya les neveu de napoléon dont
louis napoléon le plus jeune finira par
accéder au trône après moult tentatives
de coup d'état ratée et souvent
ridicules pourquoi est ce qu'une jeune
fille qu'il sort de nulle part
serait-elle plus dangereuse à votre avis
à ce moment là en 1815
pourquoi est-ce que c'est elle qui
attire une telle méfiance alors que
l'aube à bien d'autres qui se battre
alors il faut bien voir qu en 1815 les
garçons soient l'aiguelongue où les deux
fils naturel sont encore des enfants
charlotte elle a 20 ans elle a 20 ans et
puisqu'elle est née en 1795 si elle est
vraiment fille naturelle de napoléon
elle est l'aînée
elle est l'aînée et ça compte dans les
successions dynastiques
et puis c'est une femme c'est une femme
par ailleurs c'est pas n'importe quelle
femme
son affaire est intéressante aussi parce
que c'est une femme qui a beaucoup de
ressources
elle est belle elle est vive elle est
intelligente elle a reçut une éducation
elle sait écrire elle sait charmer et
donc elle a un art très napoléonien de
retourner les situations a priori
désespérée en trouvant des alliances
auxquelles on ne pense pas en trouvant
des soutiens elle a un fort charisme et
une volonté du cran du courage autant de
qualité ou de défaut du point de vue du
ministre de la police générale qui la
rendent redoutable elle a un vrai sens
politique
au moins pour préserver ses intérêts il
faut voir quand 1815
c'est une vagabonde admis prostituées en
fait et vingt ans plus tard on va la
retrouver
l'une des femmes les plus riches de son
département alors qu'elle aurait dû
croupir toute sa vie au fond d'un cachot
donc c'est quelqu'un
charlotte chappuis elle a vraiment un
caractère et une volonté incroyable et
c'est vrai que dans le contexte de
l'époque
une femme qui ressemble à l'empereur qui
a toutes ses qualités mais qui en plus
la jeunesse et le charme d'une jeune
française de l'époque c'est quelque
chose de redoutables en particulier pour
le pouvoir d'un roi obèses et pau
d'agréer impopulaires comme louis xviii
comme vous l'avez dit elle est très
jolie il ya pas mal de gens qui
voudraient bien l'épouser on va pas
rentrer dans tous les détails à vous les
raconter
dans votre livre elle va finir par se
marier en suisse en ce en se sauvant
avec un avec un jeune homme de bonne
famille jacobs muller la famille muller
ne veut pas entendre parler de cette de
cette aventurière donc ils vont se
marier en suisse
et puis reviennent et ils vont fonder
une grande famille avec beaucoup
d'enfants saad venir des gens très
fortunés vous l'avez la liste des
maîtres de forges et alors ce qu'il ya
d'extraordinaire c'est vous avez
découvert ce seuil ce tableau c'est un
genre descendants qui vous l'a qui vous
la montrer pour la première fois où on
voit pour la première fois un charlotte
elle est ici avec son mari au milieu
d'eux de sa famille quel effet ça vous a
fait quand vous l'avez vu pour la
première fois si vous étiez déjà en
train de travailler sur elle depuis un
moment oui une émotion extraordinaire
songé ça pesait environ sept ans que je
travaillais sur mes dossiers d'archivés
sur ces documents mais qui sont des
manuscrits
je n'avais pas son visage par des sites
de généalogie j'ai retrouvé ses
descendants actuels qui eux aussi
avaient des documents donc nous sommes
rencontrés pour confronter les documents
et dans cet échange de leur ai dit voilà
ma seule frustration c'est que je n'ai
jamais retrouvé un dessin une gravure
quoi que ce soit avec le visage de
charlotte chappuis est là mon
interlocuteur m'a souri et m'a dit mais
nous nous avons un tableau
il m'a montré la photo de ce tableau et
regardez ce visage est-ce que
franchement ça n'est pas un visage de
bonaparte regarder ses yeux ce n'est la
noirceur des cheveux c'est vraiment
incroyable
par ailleurs je me suis amusé à comparer
ce visage aussi à celui de la mer
de napoléon on est ici à ramolino à ceux
de ses soeurs il ya aussi des
ressemblances qui sont extrêmement
troublantes
bien sûr on peut dire oui mais elle a
fait là elle a payé un peintre pour
accentuer la ressemblance mais c'est un
tableau qui au départ n'était pas fait
pour être montré à l'extérieur c'était
un tableau de famille elle est avec son
mari ses enfants
c'est resté pendant des décennies dans
le cercle familial et pas de volonté de
propagande de prouver quoi que ce soit
on imagine mal qu'elle soit fait
portraiturer avec un autre visage que le
sien donc au moment où j'ai vu ce visage
après des années à décortiquer des
documents et à et à poursuivre dans à
travers les archives
toutes les traces tous les indices
possibles sur la vie de charlotte
chappuis ça a été un moment d'émotion
tant que je n'avais pas vu ce portrait
j'ai pu aussi y est me dire oui c'est
une belle histoire d' imposture mais
c'est une aventurière elle elle
déclarait quelque chose de faux là
j'avoue que j'ai été extrêmement troublé
quand j'ai vu ce tableau mai puis par
ailleurs j'ai retrouvé des photographies
de l'un de ses fils on voit enfin sur le
tableau mais qui va grandir oui on les
verra après parce qu'effectivement les
photos assez amusante mais il faut bien
voir comment on la voit là trôner au
milieu de sa famille vous l'avez dit
elle est très riche elle reçoit dans son
salon napoléon elle reçoit tous les
anciens de la grande armée qui passe et
qui ont besoin d'un peu d'argent
et puis surtout 1848 au moment de
l'élection présidentielle
quand louis napoléon bonaparte est
candidat elle reçoit une lettre lui
demande de soutenir louis napoléon
bonaparte tel triomphe
et oui là c'est la jonction qui se perd
entre le chef officiel de la famille
bonaparte et puis cette fille naturelle
qui jusqu'àlors vivait en marge
elle est puissante dans l'est de la
france à elle s'est établie dans le jura
à champagnole où son mari possède une
force donc un industriel très riche et
c'est une ancienne dames de compagnie de
la reine hortense qui au nom de louis
napoléon bonaparte prend contact lui ai
écrit lui demande si elle peut soutenir
ça veut dire financés
veut dire faire un petit peu campagne
pour louis napoléon bonaparte est
clairement elle va le faire
on sait par d'autres sources que lorsque
louis napoléon bonaparte sera au pouvoir
et bien elle va le soutenir publiquement
elle l'appelle mon cousin c'est quand
même très clair et lorsqu'elles entrent
dans ces établissements où il ya deux à
trois cents ouvriers et bien à la
légende c'est que les ouvriers posent
leurs outils et crie vive l'empereur et
on ne sait pas trop s'il salue napoléon
1er napoléon iii ou tout simplement
charlotte qui est un petit peu
l'impératrice de québécois une sorte
d'empereur en jupon bedous le destin de
son fils celui qu'on voit d'ailleurs
dans ses bras là encore poupaud et qui
va devenir le maire de champagnole en
on va voir sa photo et et lui lui il s'y
croit vraiment alors vous avez vu nous
le montrer à côté de de son grand père
putatif d'appeler au c'est vrai qu'on
peut trouver un air de ressemblance mais
un air de ressemblance qui va
s'accentuer à partir du moment où un web
ria muller voilà va prendre la pose
cette photo évidemment a dû vous ravir
cette photo est extraordinaire
exceptionnel nous sommes à une époque où
ça coûte très cher de se faire
photographier en plus cette photo a été
prise au studio petit être un quart qui
était le comble du chic sous le second
empire
donc ça n'est pas du tout par hasard
c'est pas par fantaisie c'est très
réfléchie il ya même une espèce de
traîne derrière lui que l'on voit donc
ils minent clairement celui qu'il
considère comme étant son grand-père et
cette photo elle a vraiment une
signification étonnante elle était
inconnue des descendants mais les
descendants
m'ont dit que eux aujourd'hui encore en
eh bien apprenez dès l'enfance qu'il
descendait de napoléon 1er
donc vraiment cette tradition familiale
s'est transmise à travers cinq six
générations et c'est vrai que cette
photo d'adrien muller maire de
champagnole conseiller général candidat
à la députation est très significative
il faut savoir qu adrien müller en plus
à bénéficier de l'éducation politique
d'un parent qui n'était pas le premier
venu
le général de l'or un authentique
général d'empiré qui avait connu
napoléon dont le nom est gravé sur l'arc
de triomphe et qui a en quelque sorte
éduquer politiquement ce garçon donc
loyer une dynastie qui s'est fondée qui
ne réclament pas la couronne impériale
de france mais qui est très fière
d'avoir du sang bonaparte et et cette
tradition qui jusqu'àlors était
familiale un peu confidentiel un peu
locale et bien maintenant est connu
grâce à ce dossier d' archives qui
dormait dans un grenier que j'ai eu la
chance extraordinaire de découvrir
alors évidemment on pense l'adn
aujourd'hui on est en 2021
il suffirait d'un test adn mais vous
avez l'air de dire que c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'on ne le croit pour
être certain que ils sont les
descendants de l'appeler au premier
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qu'une caisse
qui s'oppose aujourd'hui à à
l'utilisation d'une preuve pareil
souvent il ya peu une pensée magique de
l'adn j'ai interrogé un généticien dont
vraiment le métier d'établir comme cela
est d'identifier des corps d'identifier
des personnes
bon on qu'on connaît l'adn y pardon le
chromosome y de napoléon 1er mai le
chromosome y c'est celui qui se transmet
de père en fils
ça ne marche pas avec une fille l'adn
mitochondrial se transmet de la mer à la
fille pas du père à la fille donc là
aussi ça ne fonctionne pas il faudrait
donc analysé l'adn nucléaire d'une part
en ayant un échantillon sur deux
napoléon 1er d'autre part en ouvrant la
tombe de charlotte chappuis donc ça
nécessite de nombreuses autorisations y
compris du ministère des armées pour ce
qui est de la tombe des invalides à vous
me direz qu'il existe des reliques
napoléonienne un petit peu partout mais
en fait les cheveux les mèches de
cheveux ça ne vaut rien si on n'a pas le
bulbe le le simple cheveux ne permet pas
d'accéder au type dha des haines qui
permettrait de faire la preuve
ou alors il faudrait un échantillon
organique mais d'après ce que j'ai pu
voir les dans les morceaux de peau qui
ont pu passer en salle des ventes où se
trouvaient dans des musées ici et là ont
tous une provenance contesté voire très
contestable il faut voir qu'il ya eu
tout un commerce des reliques
napoléonienne au 19ème 20ème siècle et
on n'est pas toujours bien certain que
tel ou tel morceau de napoléon si j'ose
dire soit vraiment de napoléon il
faudrait en fait ouvrir son tombeau aux
invalides
il faudrait ouvrir la tombe de charlotte
chappuis est là seulement on pourrait
avoir une indication de probabilité on
saurait si c'est impossible où on
saurait si c'est à un certain
pourcentage possible on aura de toute
façon jamais la preuve scientifique et
avec les descendants non c'est
impossible ça c'est assez cassé parce
qu'on est dans une transmission
essentiellement par voie féminine
ce qui est terrible dans cette histoire
c'est que la plupart des garçons n'ont
pas eu de descendance mêmes l'aîné de
charlotte chappuis est devenu
complètement fou comme s'il était
impossible de porter sur les épaules
d'un jeune homme une hérédité une
paternité pareil et donc la transmission
s'est faite essentiellement par les
filles charlotte puis sa fille puis
c'est sa petite fille etc
mais il faut dire aussi que tout cela
n'a strictement aucune importance
puisque ils n'ont jamais rien revendiqué
en tout cas sur le plan politique et
finalement on s'en fiche qu'elle était
ou pas la fille d'appeler au ca se
trouve napoléon a eu d'autres enfants
naturels kino à qui on n'a jamais
raconté leur histoire peut être même que
la les leur mère ne savait pas que vous
avez eu affaire au lieutenant ou au
capitaine bonaparte
tout ça n'a aucune importance bruno
fuligni l'histoire n'a aucune importance
sinon celle qu'on veut bien lui donner
la fille de napoléon elle est
intéressante parce qu'elle nous révèle
de son temps de son époque du contexte à
la fois cette période très instable
très peu sur de 1815 et de la
restauration les peurs de cette époque
là elle est à elle toute seule a résumé
du 19e siècle qui commence avec les
canonnades des batailles napoléoniennes
et qui se termine avec la grande
industrie la sidérurgie la révolution
industrielle on parle de la révolution
politique à la révolution industrielle
moi c'est beaucoup ça qui m'a intéressé
dans le destin de charlotte chappuis il
s'agit pas de mettre sur le trône de l'
empire français une nouvelle branche des
bonaparte c'est vraiment pas mon propos
il s'agit plutôt d'explorer une époque à
travers un personnage qui jusqu'àlors
était totalement inconnu et que j'ai pu
ressusciter en quelque sorte
grâce à ces documents vous savez sur
napoléon on a coutume de dire qu'on sait
tous qu'on croit tout savoir avoir tous
publiés il ya eu des milliers de livres
sur napoléon et c'est vrai que pour un
historien découvrir un dossier
complètement inédit sur une affaire de
cette importance lié à napoléon 1er
c'est un rêve et c'est un rêve qui s'est
réalisé en ce qui concerne je discute
pas que ça avait de l'importance à
l'époque je disais c'est aujourd'hui au
fond quelle importance laura cela
aurait-il de savoir si elle était
vraiment sa fille ou pas aujourd'hui ça
ça n'a pas de ça n'a pas de conséquence
à part pour ceux qui se réclament de
cette de cette ascendance prestigieuse
le livre s'intitule la fille de napoléon
et il est paru il est paru chez qui
d'ailleurs j'ai oublié aux éditions des
arènes on se retrouve juste après une
pause
[Musique]
mélina gars si vous vous êtes
journaliste et avec suzanne kerssenberg
et la dessinatrice de go margut plus une
préface de julie gayet vous publiez
elles ont été les premières aux éditions
de la martinière vous y fait le portrait
de 100 femmes exceptionnelles qui ont
concouru chacune à leur manière à
l'avènement du girl power
alors comment les avez vous choisi parce
que l ont été les premières d'accord
mais pourquoi dans ce cas comment c'est
vous ce livre avec jeanne barre et pas
avec eve la première femme créée par
dieu à partir d'une côte d'adam et
pourquoi n'y figurent pas griselda
blanco la pionnière du trafic de cocaïne
aux états unis avant même pablo escobar
ou jeanne weber l'ogresse de la goutte
d'or la première clause en série
d'enfants en 1908 ou kylie jenner la
demi soeur de kim kardashian devenu à 21
ans la plus jeune milliardaire de
l'histoire avec son affaire de
cosmétiques elle aurait le droit d'être
là tout aussi bien écouté j'ai fait un
choix qui est forcément un choix
arbitraire avec l'idée que toute façon
au départ il n'avait peut-être pas
autant
et puis s'est avéré qu'il y avait
beaucoup de femmes qui étaient les
premières et je me suis fait cette
réflexion je reprends je vous vos femmes
les femmes que vous citez je pense que
ça mériterait effectivement
de faire une seconde un tome enfin tome
2 parce qu'il ya des tas de votre femme
la première femme qui a été ta tuer la
première femme qui est devenue une
grande directrice d'une grande
entreprise de cosmétiques étaient une
transgenre
il y en a beaucoup d'autres donc
effectivement j'ai même pris le soin
dans la petite note de premières pages
de dire on en a oublié beaucoup il y en
a encore beaucoup d'autres il fallait
faire un choix et donc alors voilà c'est
un choix qui n'est pas qui effectivement
est à la fois personnel et tout à fait
enfin kim qui j'ai choisi j'ai fait un
choix parmi ses premières alors vous me
parliez dave vont alors moi j'ai pas
voulu parler des vrais jeux je comprends
ce que vous voulez dire mais bon là je
voulais pas rentrer dans dans une
dans une question quand même où la
religion a beaucoup à voir quand même en
tout cas certains croyante je voulais
être plus détaché de cela donc c'est un
choix qui est tout à fait personnelle et
toute façon qui n'est pas exhaustif et
toutes ces femmes
j'espère tout c'est 100 femmes seront
suivies d'un autre tome peut-être il y
en aura-t-il sans peut-être y en
aura-t-il - mais déjà ces femmes là pour
la plupart d'entre elles elles ne sont
elles sont assez peu connu oui par
exemple la première avec elle vous
ouvrez le livre avec elle c'est jacques
barré et jeunes barré alors vraiment
cela personnage totalement history pour
voit l'illustration sortie du livre
jaune barré elle se déguise en homme
pour accompagner son amoureux qui est un
savant botaniste qui a la chance
d'embarquer pour le premier tour du
monde français et il est il est sur le
bateau et elle elle se déguise en homme
et elle elle passe pour son valet et
elle va être la première femme à avoir
fait le tour du monde
c'est une aventure assez extraordinaire
celle de jean bart et c'est d'autant
plus extraordinaire que que c'est une
femme un peu campagnarde on va dire au
départ qui se retrouve dans une
situation comme beaucoup de femmes ou
d'autres personnages connaît ça veut
dire ses parents meurent si je me
souviens bien se retrouve obligé de
s'engager comme nurse chez ceux de
philippe commerçants qui est qui qui va
devenir effectivement qui va être
désigné pour faire partie d'une
exposition de bougainvilliers donc voila
et de gouvernante à lui il tombe
amoureux
la nana la femme de ce botaniste est
morte en couches il se trouve que de
gouvernante elle devient l'amoureuse du
du botaniste et et comme elle a eu la
chance quand même de d'apprendre des
choses de ses parents et de sa mère en
particulier des feuilles dans les arbres
des choses de la campagne et
ça l'intéresse et ça n'intéresse de plus
en plus et elle veut absolument faire
partie de l'expédition
peut-être pour ne pas laisser partir son
amoureux mais aussi parce que je pense
que ça n'intéresse et la suite de
l'histoire est formidable parce que en
fait elle est effectivement déguisée en
homme puisqu'il est interdit et pour une
femme de faire partie d'une expédition
mais finalement le j'ai une sympathie
pour boga villiers parce que finalement
aller un petit peu reconnue en tant que
femme parce que on se dit quand même
c'est bizarre cette petits moussaillons
où ce petit secrétaire ou ce petit valet
c'est curieux et elle finit par être
démasqué et bouna vulliez ferme les yeux
et il continue la route et je trouve ça
aussi formidable parce que il faut aussi
saluer les hommes qui ont aidé certaines
femmes à devenir ce qu'elles sont ou à
permettre de les faire rentrer dans dans
un chemin où elle voulait rentrer et la
ville jeudi dans l'introduction vous
bien ville lui rendra hommage d'ailleurs
dans ses mémoires et quand elle
reviendra en france louis saez
reconnaîtra ses mérites en tant
qu'assistant de botanistes et et lui
versera une une pension d'ailleurs comme
quoi ça se finit bien l'histoire de
jeanne barrez vous avez choisi melita
benz aussi alors mes limites à ben c'est
elle qui a inventé le filtre à café
elle a créé une énorme entreprise on
parle du café melita en fait melita
c'est le nom des filtres elle a donné
aux filtres son propre prénom c'est une
sacrée nana melita benz
enfin elle a pas assez pas une première
oui c'est la première à avoir inventé un
filtre again fait quoi oui mais écoutez
moi j'ai pas voulu faire un
un livre sur les premières coin de
goûter des choses forcément
extraordinaire qui ont révolutionné
encore quelle le filtre à café
il sait rester dans la mémoire
collective
et puis j'ai voulu m'amuser aussi j'ai
voulu m'amuser a montré que ce n'était
pas seulement des mathématicienne des
biologistes des familles rue dit bon des
grands écrivains etc qui avait aussi des
femmes qui ont inventé des choses comme
la filtre à café
moi j'ai quand même passé toute mon
enfance avec ses filtres à café alors
aujourd'hui évidemment ça paraît
complètement hors de enfin la société
mais dit ah ben c'est transformé puisque
je pense que des filtres à café
ils sont assez peu utilisées aujourd'hui
où les capsules je vais pas citer les
noms mais font florès partout dans le
monde et en france en particulier mais
quand même c'est moi j'ai voulu m'amuser
à montrer des femmes que plus personne
connaît et qui sont assez peu reconnus
parce que effectivement inventer des
filtres à café
c'est pas comme
comme valentina terechkova là par
exemple est la première femme dans
l'espace en 1963 c'est vrai qu'elle est
un peu oublié aujourd'hui alors que l a
été à l'époque c'était hallucinant on
est un an combien deux ans après
gagarine et les soviétiques en voit une
femme peut dire d'ailleurs les l'urss
c'est un stud mine pour votre livre
parce que c'est dans ce pays où il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes qui se sont
retrouvés à accomplir des premières fois
le rsa sa bien-aimée mettre en avant des
femmes alors vous les avez pas tout de
suite aimé les premières femmes les as
dans la chasse de pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est tout des femmes
soviétique qui était aux commandes
d'avions de chasse et qui se battaient
exactement comme des hommes mais ça vous
avez raison effectivement alors d'autant
plus elles sont nombreuses même si j'ai
pas citer toutes ces femmes là qui
feront peut-être partie d'ailleurs l'une
d'un tome 2 de ces femmes
exceptionnelles mais finalement elles
sont quand même assez nombreuses
si on considère que maintenant dans le
dans mes choix parce que par exemple il
ya beaucoup d'américaines qui sont
d'origine
russe ou parce que effectivement
l'amérique à une part importante mais
c'est parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'immigration comme vous le savez que et
que donc on vient en amérique on est en
droit on est rue sonné et c'est donc les
russes effectivement donne un bon tribut
à ces premières yahad à byron alors là
elle l on la connaît un petit peu les
dix loveless la fille de lord byron à
qui l'on doit le le premier programme
informatique en tout cas l'ancêtre de de
l'algorithme du programme informatique
c'est une fille qui est très très jeune
à l'époque et qui se passionne pour les
maths elle est assez extraordinaire l on
commence à la découvrir
on a commencé à la découvrir il ya
quelques années entre autres enfin en
tout cas à paris avec une exposition qui
avait lieu à la gaîté lyrique que
j'avais trouvé assez assez marrante
assez drôle
la gaîté lyrique est un endroit où on en
tout cas c'est un je dis pas c'est
amuser mais en tout cas c'est un musée
un lieu d'exposition on met en avant
tout ce qui a trait à la poule haute
technologie et mon nouvel an nouveau
réseau etc
il y avait une exposition qui s'appelait
computer girl et on lui rendait hommage
je pense que c'est un personnage
extraordinaire d'abord parce que quand
même elle est la fille de byron qui est
quand même c'est pas rien mais ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est quand même que
sa mère à détourner l'attention et
l'intérêt de sa fille pour les lettres
donc elle n'a pas suivi le chemin de son
père et
là beaucoup sa mère l'à beaucoup
[Musique]
beaucoup il a beaucoup intéressé aux
mathématiques et quand même elle est
devenue cette formidable femme de matt
et je trouve que c'est assez
voilà j'ai trouvé ça savoureux cette
histoire de deux lada byron no contest
de l'ogc nice
alors c'est une des plus connues quand
même parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui
elle est un peu plus connu par non
seulement par le le fait qu'il ya eu
cette exposition il ya une rue à paris
dans ce nouveau quartier du xiiie tu
porte son nom bon on commence un peu à
reconnaître ada byron pour ce qu'elle
est l'emploi une femme de lettres mais
les femmes de mac les femmes
mathématicienne ça a l'air d'être une
malédiction n'arrête pas de dire que les
femmes sont meilleures que les garçons
au lycée en mathématiques et pourtant on
se plaint qu'elle ne fasse pas d'étude
mathématiques plus poussée je sais pas
si c'est toujours vrai aujourd'hui mais
vous prenez le cas de mariam milliard à
camille qui figurent dans ce livre c'est
la première femme à avoir reçu la
médaille fields de mathématiques en 2014
et je crois que c'est la seule
d'ailleurs aucune autre ne ne l'a reçue
depuis et personne ne la connaît c'est
une iranienne au départ elle a émigré
aux états unis et l'irak amis on devrait
donner son nom à des lycées mais non on
ne le fait pas oui alors c'est moi ce
qui m'a bon moi j'ai jamais eu la bosse
des maths mais je trouve que justement
j'ai voulu donner un peu le but faire
des portraits de femmes que personne ne
connaissait il y en a qui sont très
connus évidemment curie et c'est marie
curie n'a beaucoup d'autres marguerite
yourcenar
angela merkel etc
mais comme cette myriam mise misera cani
non mais c'est très c'est ayant plus
j'ai trouvé que sa vie alors non
seulement à lier cet extraordinaire
quand même c'est fait
les compliments qu'on lui fait que son
directeur de thèse du fait qu il dit que
c'est la porte ouverte à toutes les
nouvelles perspectives pour les jeunes
filles
enfin c'est extraordinaire et moi j'ai
été très émue par cette par l'histoire
de cette femme que personne connaît que
moi même si je n'avais pas fait de
recherches sur ce livre probablement je
ne connaîtrais pas encore que je me suis
beaucoup intéressé aux mathématiques il
ya quelques années et que je pense que
sa vie c'est terrible quoi elle est
finalement morte d'un cancer du sein la
carotte ont très tôt trop tôt et et oui
je 40 ans et voilà j'ai trouvé je
trouvais que c'était un rembrandt dhr
hommage à cette fille qui a quand même
eu eu une trajectoire absolument
éblouissante et qui j'espère créera des
vocations
alors c'est drôle parce qu'aujourd'hui
on s'intéresse à celles qui ont ouvert
la voie dans l'informatique ou grandes
mathématicienne mais au début du 20e
siècle celle qui après sionnel c'était
celle qui venait sur le terrain des
hommes et notamment le terrain de la
vitesse et il y en a plusieurs dans
votre livre il ya camille du gast
camille du gast qui est la première
femme à obtenir l'équivalent à l'époque
du permis de conduire on est en 1898 qui
va s'illustrer dans la course automobile
qui va être je crois la première à
sauter en parachute aussi donc c'est une
c'est une sacrée une sacrée nana comme
on dit comme on disait en tout cas à
cette époque là et puis à elisa de roche
qui elle un peu plus tard en 1910 est la
première femme à obtenir le brevet de
pilote d'avion
elle va battre des tas de records en
altitude elle et elle est extraordinaire
et pendant la guerre de 14
je crois pas que vous le racontez
message que je le savais elle essaye par
tous les moyens de s'engager dans la
phase elle veut faire le l étude des
meilleurs pilotes en france elle a son
propre avion
elle demande à être engagés dans la
chasse dans l'armée de l'air et on lui
refuse
on lui on lui rocchetti sione son avion
mais on lui refuse de se battre contre
contre les allemands elle finira par
mourir d'ailleurs dans un accident
aérien de cd payne qui était aux
commandes c'était un homme
mais mais généreux c'est l'hallu ronnie
de la vie il visait de roche c'est quand
même un sacré personnage de clara zetkin
aussi qui est la première propriétaire
de d'un journal
car hazeltine un mot sur elle une russe
elle aussi alors elle allait elle est
assez incroyable parce que évidemment
nous on a des grandes figures sur le sur
la sur les femmes qui ont qui s'engagé
pour la journée
elle est la première une des premières à
proposer une journée du 8 mars quand
même en 1910 et puis elle lui vient
d'une famille tout à fait de plus beaux
joizil qu'il n'aurait jamais dû épouser
les thèses révolutionnaires et donc elle
rencontre un étudiant russe son vin en
russie enfin c'est quand même une une
femme évidemment qui est beaucoup moins
connu que d'autres femmes mais à qui on
doit certainement le la journée du 8
mars 1910 28 mars qu'est devenu les
journées internationales une journée
consacrée aux droits des femmes et donc
j'ai voulu effectivement en showcase à
la scène livre elle a demandé cette
journée à 8 mars le 8 mars 2009 110 et
que c'est cette journée qui est devenue
la journée nationale des femmes je
prends au 77 on appris la date du 8 mars
parce que c'était la date qu'elle avait
proposé 60 cents un an auparavant
il ya également alors la première femme
élue démocratiquement c'est dans un pays
d'asie c'est alors elle a un nom très
difficilement prononçable c'est sirimavo
bandaranaike elle est élue en 1960 elle
devient elle elle devient la chef de
l'état sri lankais en 1960 alors bon
c'est la fille de l'ancien premier
ministre de l'ancien premier ministre
assassiné comme c'est arrivé souvent
mais c'est vrai que c'est en asie au
fond que les femmes arrivent au pouvoir
je parle dans les états démocratiques
plus plus rapidement qu'en europe la
première véritable ans et lui sait c'est
gold amer en israël et puis il ya une
dire à gandhi en inde
il y en a une au pakistan c'est plus
souvent en asie qu'en europe 1 que les
femmes arrivent au pouvoir en tout cas
plus vite
ben écoutez c'est pour moi c'était un
peu inouïe
parce que ça je le savais avant d'avoir
eu l'idée de ce livre mais c'est inouï
parce qu'effectivement non seulement
alors c'est vrai que la tradition veut
dans dans dans ce pays qu effectivement
on donne à la femme le une grande grande
d'un grand pouvoir à la mort du du mari
m'enfin quand même elle a été non
seulement est élu mais elle a été après
trois fois si ma mémoire est bonne
trois fois ministre et après sa fille a
poursuivi le chemin alors peut-être
effectivement celle c'était quand même
bien avant une derrag andy d'abord et
puis même si la première vraiment
officiel c'est gold amer c'est quand
même assez remarquable et finalement
vous avez raison de le souligner ce soir
au sri lanka que on a on a vu les femmes
en russe ce pouvoir-là de diriger un
pays et
c'est assez étonnant en 1960
ça paraît ça paraît presque une histoire
inventée mais pourtant c'est vrai ya
evelyne b résine qui avant que le
traitement de texte en 1968 elle aussi
voilà quelqu'un qui on pourrait le
donner le nom d'ali c'est parce qu'on a
toujours des lycées sophie germain en
france personne c'est d'ailleurs se
figea m'a bien que c'était une météo
haïtienne d'importance enfin yvelines
bérézina elle mériterait sont ici y'a
stefanik wollek qui invente le kevlar en
voilà un nom alors que vous n'avez
jamais entendu parler bah écoutez moi je
suis assez contente de de faire part et
de parler de femmes dont on dont comme
moi même je dois l'avouer je ne
connaissais pas à part quelques unes au
départ parce que effectivement c'est
ahurissant que cette femme est inventé
une matière qui aujourd'hui se
retrouvent dans pleins d'articles de
sport 2 2 les casques de moto les
raquettes de tennis et j'en passe et
donc je balançais c'était aussi mon une
une volonté pour moi de parler des
grandes qui sont incontournables
évidemment mais aussi de parler de deux
femmes dont on ne connaît absolument pas
le nom ou si on l'a connu on l'a
complètement oublié en tout cas la 2ème
evelyne des résines et estevan eu comme
l'est qu'on les connaît absolument pas
donc je veux le rend hommage en
racontant un peu leur vie une façon
succincte puisque le principe c'est un
portrait est une illustration
et je trouve que alors pour je voudrais
juste dire un mot sur les illustrations
je remercie goma revue qui a fait toutes
les femmes debout
oui c'est vrai voilà pour la plupart de
vous voilà effectivement à part deux ou
deux ou trois bon j'avoue d'ailleurs
est-ce que c'était 1-1
vous savez on ne sait pas d'où viennent
des choses est ce que c'est un principe
de départ
j'avoue que je pourrai pas vous le dire
aujourd'hui je crois que nous n'avons
pas décidé comme à regret mois de 2,2
d'années dans dans ce chemin là des
femmes debout mais peut-être que ça a
été instinctif et c'est très bien il ya
beaucoup de femmes noires américaines
qui ont été les premières dans leur
domaine aux états unis et d'ailleurs on
voit que le cinéma ou les séries
commencent à leur rendre hommage vous je
vais en citer qu'une c'est madame si
jimmy walker qui est la première femme
d'affaires noir aux états unis et qui a
inventé une ligne de produits
cosmétiques et capillaires
il ya eu un film sur l chez netflix mais
il y en a d'autres
il ya celles qui était ingénieur à la
haye la nasa quand on a envoyé pendant
la mission au pôle eaux un film leur a
rendu hommage également
voilà l on commence à les connaître rosa
parks elle l a beaucoup beaucoup de
lycées on connaît moins le clos des de
colvin qui a fait la même chose que
claude a et que rosa parks mais avant et
qui était bien plus jeune elle avait 15
ans et
et elle même a refusé de donner sa place
à un blanc dans l'autobus
elle avait d'ailleurs pour conseillère
rosa parks qui limitera quelques mois
plus tard mais bon comment ça tout à
toutes les connaître un celle ci en
revanche et marguerite durand qui fait
le premier journal féministe en 1897
entièrement écrits par des femmes et l
on la connaît pas alors on la connaît
pas il faut quand même dire qu'à paris
en tout cas jeudi à paris et las il n'ya
peut-être je ne sais pas s'il y en a
d'autres en france sur le territoire
français mais il ya une lio tech qui
s'appelle marguerite durand à paris dans
le xiiie qui a été fermée etc est de
nouveau ouverte sur l'esplanade des
olympiades qui est une bibliothèque où
on trouve un trésor de de renseignements
c'est d'ailleurs dans cette bibliothèque
où je suis pour la première fois aller
travailler quand j'ai vu cette idée il y
a plus de dix ans j'avais cette idée de
faire déjà de quelque chose sur les
femmes première et puis la vie et le le
travail m'a fait faire d'autres choses
mais cette biotech existe et elle et
elle est assez incroyable parce que
effectivement on n'imagine pas qu'on
imagine que cette marguerite durand est
une combattante elle l'est évidemment
mais elle est une femme mondaine aussi
on la voit avec démandé de la fourrure
est et je trouve ça assez assez drôle
parce que d'ailleurs on la voit sur
l'image on la voit bien à elle est
assise sur un fauteuil comme assia
élégant on voit bien que quand même une
femme entre guillemets du monde
en tout cas elle n'est pas et les elle
appartient à certains milieux
mais enfin le culot quand même deux
de dire moi j'ai pas envie de devenir
journaliste dans un journal où on me
demande de ne pas écrire ceci sur les
femmes de ne pas faire ceci sur les
femmes
moi je vais créer mon propre journal je
trouve que c'est assez culotté à
l'époque
et puis le nom la fronde aujourd'hui ça
fait sourire mais je trouve que ces
femmes avaient sen avait une
qu'elles soient de la haute bourgeoisie
de de la petite province ou pauvres je
crois qu'elle j'avais quand même 1 1
un certain en tout cas je suis simple
motivation c'est sur une scène de la
beauty motivation parce qu'ils sont plus
que ça il ya un une peut-être un
engagement très fort enfin alors qu'on
pense que les femmes sont plutôt timides
plutôt réservés en tout cas celle dont
je parlais sel vont se passerait
peut-être dans un tome 2 elles ont une
réserve de 2,2 de personnalités dedans
vie qui est in qui force l'admiration
il y en a plein d'autres maria tel qu
est-ce qui l'on doit la première maison
chauffée à l'énergie solaire il ya
joséphine garris cochrane qui inventait
le premier lave vaisselle et aviva bête
magee qui a inventé le monopoly bien
avant le monopoly ça s'appelait le jeu
du propriétaire est touchée d'ailleurs
500 dollars de droits d'auteur quand le
monopoly a été commercialisé mais je
voudrais un dernier mot de bruno fuligni
qui est historien cette galerie de
femmes vous inspire quoi
ah bah écoute et de la sympathie de
l'intérêt c'est vrai qu'il ya des
personnalités que je découvre d'autres
que j'ai déjà rencontré comme marguerite
durand femme extraordinaire elle avait
quand même une panthère apprivoiser
autre s'est présenté aux élections les
caricaturistes ont représenté en train
de coller des affiches avec la queue de
sa panthère elle avait présenté comme
les femmes ne pouvaient pas
faire de réunions électorales et se
présente est véritablement elle était
assez cruelle elle avait trouvé un
espèce de demeurer qui lui avait le
droit de vote et donc elle avait
présenté en 1910 le candidat idiot et
donc elle et ses amies mettaient en
scène un pauvre homme pour handicapé
mental en dix ans le voilà lui est
complètement débile il a le droit de se
présenter et voter et nous qui sommes
auteur de livres de rédactrice de
journaux de lave ont aucun droit
donc ça montre aussi que ces femmes qui
était plein de ressources étaient aussi
des femmes assez dur c'était vraiment
des combattantes et à une époque où la
vie politique était peut-être encore
plus dure qu'aujourd'hui
eh bien elles ont montré qu'elle avait
un petit peu le cuir épais et c'est vrai
que ma charlotte cherifi de napoléon est
un peu de cette trempe là aussi des
femmes qui avaient beaucoup de charme
beaucoup de chiens mais aussi une
volonté incroyable et une certaine
dureté qui allait de pair avec leurs
ressources ne peut pas faire l'histoire
de des siècles passés en occultant les
femmes elles ont joué un rôle parfois de
premier plan parfois en coulisse souvent
décisif merci tous les deux elles ont
été les premières
le livre est paru aux éditions de la
martinière
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]